let's talk about something it's probably
near and dear to your heart the travel
ban you immigrated from Iran at a very
young age how old were you when you left
Iran yeah I was let's see I well we left
Iran right after I was born and my my
dad was able to come straight to the
United States you and your mom went yeah
we had to go to Germany and so we lived
there for a year
waiting for us visas and then I met my
dad at the airport in LA when I was
three when you were three you kind of
got your dad and we have a first time we
have a picture here I think that your
mom took of you meeting your dad when
you were three what a mind-blowing
experience yeah he's trying to hug me
and I'm like you're a stranger please
step away that was yes you probably have
strong feelings about what's happening
right now
yeah that's pretty intense yeah and yeah
well it's it's obviously a very
complicated matter but I personally you
know feel like it's an executive order
that's misguided and non American and a
lot of people would argue not the right
way to protect our country yeah I think
you you came here I can't imagine
most of us obviously we we take it for
granted we were born here we are
immersed in the culture from day one
were you someone who at that age three
four or five did you want to be American
or did you want to retain some of your
heritage oh my gosh no I definitely
wanted to be seen as American like now
I'm old enough to really appreciate and
embrace my Iranian heritage but when
you're a kid you you don't want to feel
different you just want to fit in so my
cousins and I were just so so hoping
people would see us as American like
everyone else and to us
there was nothing more American than
Rocky Balboa we were obsessed with him
right like family gatherings you thought
that's how an American that is the guy
using the correct English yeah yeah and
family gatherings we would just rent
rocky screen it and then just beat the
[ __ ] out of each other most patriotic
that is the most patriotic act our
parents would be like what are you doing
and we'd be like whatever we want we're
in America now
weirdly try to talk like Stallone did
you really yeah I'd let go up to my mom
and be like Oh Adrian make me a snack
what are we waiting for
[Laughter]
we're going back
you